so with all the confidence that I could
muster I told him he needed me to open
an LA office and help him fulfill the
vision that he had
created he looked at me for a moment and
then he said yeah sure call me when you
get
there and right then and there I learned
quickly that when somebody says yes stop
talking I returned to Boston and thought
that maybe I had imagined the
conversation the next day I got the call
that forever changed my life so today
with immense gratitude I'm honored to
accept the Jean herel humanitarian award
in recognition of my lifelong work
supporting independent Visionary
filmmakers as a founding director of the
Sundance
Institute